covid just won't go away latest figures
show there have been more than 43
700 cases reported in the last 24 hours
the seventh day in a row that have been
over 40 000. there's been another 223
people who've died the highest daily
number since march though that may
partly because of delayed reporting from
the weekend so what is going on well
these are the case rates by age group
and by far the highest are in children
aged between 10 and 19 with more than
one thousand one hundred infected in
every one hundred thousand and there's
been a sharp upward trend in recent
weeks a long way behind are younger
children with a rate of 574.
then is people in their forties perhaps
the parents of those children but with a
much more gentle rise in other age
groups cases are much lower so the
current wave is still largely confined
to children who are unlikely to become
seriously ill
who's being admitted to hospital then
well the older you are the more at risk
you are and that's as true now as it was
at the start of the pandemic admission
rates in the over 85 year olds are 37 in
every 100 000 that's eight times higher
than in people between 45 and 54.
so infection rates are high in the young
and hospital admission rates are
relatively high in the old and what
draws them together is the vaccine
rollout just 16 of 12 to 15 year olds
have had their first dose there's lots
of vulnerable children and the virus is
spreading easily
in the elderly immunity is waning which
is why booster doses are being rolled
out but so far only 46 percent of the
over 80s have had a booster so again
lots of people are increasingly
vulnerable until they get their immunity
topped up
stepping up the vaccination the old and
the young is the way to stop the surgeon
infections and short-circuit the rise in
pressure on the nhs